before we go ahead and build a content
provider you wouldn't be out of line to
ask well why the simplest answer is that
it allows you to share your data safely
and efficiently across our boundaries by
abstracting the underlying data source
be it execute light like this or files
or really anything else so that other
apps can access it without really
needing to understand how you stored it
in fact the calendar SMS and contacts
api's work that way using shared content
providers we're going to share our
weather database later but if you're not
planning to expose your apps data you're
probably thinking you can skip this bit
right well almost in a lot of cases you
could but really shouldn't for example
in sunshine we're using SQLite but you
could be storing data and files dynamic
runtime data or even just a different
database library by using content
providers it's easier for you to
potentially switch out the data source
and much easier for someone other than
you to manage the UI layer code without
them having to understand the depths of
your data storage implementation on the
UI layer it's a generic mechanism that
returns cursors the same of those
returned by SQLite databases so if your
data layer implementation changes only
your content provider is affected still
it's just you writing the code right now
and that's a lot of boilerplate than the
sake of following a neat design pattern
well keep in mind that as far as the
framework is concerned all data is
handled through content providers so if
you want to interact with anything
outside of your app such as sending data
to a widget or returning search results
from within your app you'll need a
content provider for that too in fact
that's how the Google Play Store and
Gmail widgets work as well as the
ability to get search results from
Google Play similarly there's a bunch of
API is designed to optimize the process
of syncing and querying data and
updating the UI accordingly and all of
them also expect content providers that
includes sync adapters and cursor
loaders which make your app able to
efficiently think with your server load
data in your UI layer and which include
built-in content observers that will
update your UI automatically when the
underlying
Changez you could of course build all of
that yourself but at a certain point the
advantage you gained by not writing a
content provider to begin with is lost
in the process of having to recreate all
of the useful classes that utilize it
we'll take a look at publishing your
content provider and using loaders to
access it efficiently later in this
lesson and we'll explore syncadapters in
lesson 6 when we look at doing efficient
background updates but first Dan is
going to show you how to actually build
a content provider